[Music]
what are our reports on our position and
stats
call battle stations mr silva
title stations all hands to battle
stations
the star trek universe kicked off in
1966 with the original series created by
science fiction visionary gene
roddenberry and later exploded into a
massive film and tv juggernaut while the
original series which starred william
shatner's captain james c kirk and
leonard nimoy as mr spock saw only three
seasons it made an indelible impression
on the sci-fi genre mankind
ready
to kill that's the way it was in 1881
i wonder
how humanity
managed to survive
we overcame our instinct for violence
[Music]
live-action tv follow-up star trek the
next generation with patrick stewart his
captain jean-luc picard leading an
ensemble cast captivated viewers from
1987 to 1994 and inspired three more
series that would air within the next
decade deep space nine voyager and
enterprise mr wolfe
coordinate your team to dr crush on
command laforge
cess damage and injury
hi sir
in 2017 trek returned to small screens
with star trek discovery set during a
tumultuous wartime era about a decade
before the original series the year 2020
gave fans a celebration of one of its
most iconic characters with the premiere
of star trek picard and stuart reprising
his role the tv franchise has also
introduced two animated series lower
decks and prodigy and since prodigy is
meant for kids we're including it as an
honorable mention but which of the tv
and streaming series is best we are
ranking each show by tomato meter so you
may be surprised to see which show gets
number one all in unity vessels armed
and ready shield's up prepare for battle
and for completis the animated series
which ran for two seasons in the early
1970s and has a 94 tomato meter score
only has 16 reviews of its first season
so it won't be included here because of
the low number of eligible reviews with
all of that out of the way we are
ranking all star trek tv shows ranked by
tomato meter
[Music]
number eight star trek enterprise
set in the mid 22nd century over 100
years before james t kirk helmed the
famous vessel this installment of the
star trek franchise is set on the
enterprise nx01 the nx01 is the first
earth starship capable of warp 5 and
explores the history of the
interplanetary upheaval that eventually
leads to the formation of the federation
starring scott bakula connor trenir
jolene blaylock and created by rick
berman and brannon braga critics say
while some may find star trek enterprise
a welcome return to a familiar universe
it's equally as likely to repel those
uninterested in mining stories from the
franchise's past
respond
[Music]
i can't get a lock through the
camouflage
take out the emitters but don't puncture
the hull
[Music]
they do know we're on board they're
probably trying to take out the weapons
enterprise
any chance of using the transporter
[Music]
you have to get closer to the hull can
you do that we're on our way
we've lost the emitters warp status two
minutes
more enemy ships are closing
if enterprise stops the self-repair
sequence the drone
will escape
[Music]
the ship's movement is too erratic i
can't get a lock they're targeting our
warp core hole plating's at 43
36
number seven star trek voyager
catherine janeway is the captain of a
starship that is lost in space and must
travel across an unexplored region of
the galaxy to find its way back home on
its way the crew encounters different
species that they must deal with but
find that all their adventures only make
them long for home starring kate mulgrew
robert beltran roxanne dawson and
created by rick berman michael piller
and jerry taylor critics say star trek
voyager breaks the star trek mold with a
brand new final frontier and the fierce
leadership of the franchise's first
female captain
30 000 kilometers and closing target
their power core
[Music]
direct hit minor damage return fire
bridge to taurus status
i can't locate their shield grid
generator can you divert more power to
sensors standby
they've damaged our deflector captain if
it goes offline we'll be vulnerable to
the alien attacks noted
target is weapons array
torpedoes full spread
it's lana she's trying to bypass our
security protocols stop her
computer open a calm link to the equinox
workstation 33 beta
listen to me back for round two blt this
isn't one of our games
people are dying over here i wish you
didn't have to be one of them max
please
shields are weakening we've almost got
them keep targeting their weapons array
one more torpedo ought to do it captain
fire
[Music]
number six star trek
the iconic series star trek follows the
crew of the starship uss enterprise as
it completes its mission in space in the
23rd century the show follows captain
james c kirk along with half human half
vulcan science officer spock ship doctor
bones mccoy ensign chekhov
communications officer lieutenant uhura
helmsman lieutenant zulu and chief
engineer lieutenant commander scotty
scott now all of them confront strange
alien races friendly and hostile alike
as they explore unknown worlds starring
william shatner leonard nimoy nichelle
nichols and created by gene roddenberry
critics say an optimistic ode to
humanity star trek may look dated but
its gadgetry and solid storytelling
solidify its place as one of pop
culture's most enduring franchises
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
number five star trek lower decks
star trek lower decks focuses on the
support crew serving on one of star
fleet's least important ships the uss
cerritos and 2380. and signs mariner
boimler rutherford and tendy must keep
up with their duties and their social
lives often while the ship is being
rocked by a multitude of sci-fi
anomalies the ship's bridge crew
includes captain carol freeman commander
jack ransom lieutenant shax and dr tiana
this is the second animated spin-off in
the franchise after 1973-74
star trek the animated series but has a
decidedly more adult tone and humor
starring tawny newsome jack quaid noel
wells and created by mike mcmahon
critics say fun but not very bold lower
dex flips the script on star trek
regulation just enough to stand out in
the franchise if not the greater
animation landscape
[Applause]
i wasn't mad that you were stealing the
sacramento promotion i applied for those
all the time nothing ever comes with it
what now why are you freaking out
because you would have gotten it and i i
miss you okay you're my best friend oh
haven't you shared enough secrets today
just shut up
way ahead of
[Music]
sorry i mean get the captain to the bio
bed quick quick did we save the cerritos
working on it
oh i got it one legal virus but someone
has to take it to the ship but who's
small enough to go undetected yeah and
who could survive in space without a
ship someone who can travel with the
program safely stored in her hard drive
you can load the code into their ship
using your robotic abilities oh my gosh
peanut hamper you're gonna save the day
gonna pass
i i'm sorry what
number four star trek discovery
the story of star trek discovery begins
roughly a decade before captain kirk's
five-year mission as portrayed in the
original star trek from the 1960s and a
century before the events of star trek
enterprise now the series follows the
crew of the uss discovery as they
encounter new worlds and civilizations
delving into familiar themes and
expanding upon an incident that has been
talked about within the franchise's
universe but never fully explored
starring siniqua martin greene doug
jones anthony rapp and created by brian
fuller and alex kurtzman critics say
although it takes an episode to achieve
liftoff star trek discovery delivers a
solid franchise installment for the next
generation boldly led by the charismatic
synequa martin greene
[Music]
multiple torpedoes locked on us invasive
pattern delta five hi sir all power to
forward shields fire full spread
uh
[Music]
damage report preaching section two
decks nine and ten seven confirmed dead
shields at 86
shields at 82
we have a breach on deck 12. virtually
bulkheads engaged successfully
i've got a leg panel
backplate complete
we need an adjustment on 1.0 2.3 and 4.2
i'm honored i got it
number three star trek deep space nine
a spin-off with star trek the next
generation deep space nine is set on a
space station near the planet bajor this
time commander benjamin cisco is in
charge of a diverse crew but unlike
other star trek series there's no uss
enterprise to help them cisco and the
crew must fight off rival alien species
who want control of deep space nine
because of its strategic position close
to a wormhole which allows speedy travel
to the far reaches of space starring
avery brooks renee oberzanoa nana
visitor and created by rick berman and
michael piller critics say deep space
nine's first season lays the groundwork
for what could be the grittiest star
trek series yet
[Music]
the lakota's targeting their weapons on
our warp engines they're bluffing that's
a federation [ __ ] they're not going to
fire on us i hope you're right about
that chief continue on course
we're in weapons range
ratios
[Music]
damage report poor shields are at sixty
percent someone's been upgrading the
lakota's weapons
that's a lot of firepower for an
excelsior-class ship can we cloak we
would have to lower shields
i wouldn't advise it do we make a run
for it
if they've been tinkering with the
weapons who knows what they've done to
the warp drive
hail them
no answer
they're trying to disable our engines
let's go
we've got to get you to the medical mate
what do we do commander
we fight
target their weapons
fire faces
[Music]
[Music]
number two star trek the next generation
featuring a bigger and better uss
enterprise this series is set 78 years
after the original series in the 21st
century instead of captain james kirk a
less volatile and more mature captain
john luke picard heads the crew of
various humans and alien creatures in
their adventures in space the final
frontier starring patrick stewart
jonathan frakes levar burton and created
by gene roddenberry critics say it may
never be the original series but with an
exciting new mission and an expansive
ensemble star trek the next generation
proves to be an engaging introduction to
a bold new final frontier
this is captain jean-luc picard of the
uss enterprise
no response this is captain picard
representing the united federation of
planets
gainan
activate your view screen i would like
you to monitor what's going on up here
you may need your input
i'm here captain
your screen's activated i have the other
ship
you're familiar with this life form
yes
my people encountered them a century ago
they destroyed our cities
scattered my people throughout the
galaxy
they're called the borg
protect yourself captain or they'll
destroy you
shield's up
hi sir
all decks stand by
security report to maine engineering
we have an intruder
and before we get to number one here is
a quick honorable mention
star trek prodigy
a motley crew of young aliens in the
delta quadrant find an abandoned
starfleet ship the uss protostar taking
control of the ship they must learn to
work together as they make their way
towards the alpha quadrant starring kate
mulgrew riley alas rocky brett gray and
created by kevin and dan higman
shashashi from comic years says for
those who have never heard of starfleet
and by extension star trek it's a way to
discover this world and its intentions
of unity and moving forward as a
collective than the individual it's
absolutely amazing
relax i'm sure this is just a routine
systems check pull it up on screen oh
that does not look routine oh beautiful
what exactly am i looking at your course
has led us into a binary system where
the gravitational pull of an orbiting
white dwarf is in the final moments of
tearing apart a red giant a dying star
what a rare and exciting way to meet our
doom this right here is why we shouldn't
be in space for the record i tried to
caution you perhaps you'd like my help
to change course captain uh
i see what you're doing but this is my
ship
i control it be gone
your ship i said our
didn't i you just couldn't hear it over
all this noise zero get us out of here
attempting to change course
okay
appears like we're still heading
straight into it why aren't we changing
corsi it's not me we are falling into
the dwarf star's gravity well then warp
us out of here okay
doing what you told me to do just a
friendly reminder using a warp drive
inside a gravity well may result in
unpredictable and dangerous side effects
right i knew that i meant divert all the
power to the impulse engines no
so many buttons if you divert all power
you'd be deactivating victory for jacob
oh wait where'd the lady go
and finally number one star trek picard
retired admiral jean-luc picard still
deeply affected by the loss of
lieutenant commander data and the
destruction of romulus steps into the
next chapter of his life starring
patrick stewart issa briones allison
pill and created by akiva goldsman
michael chabon kirsten byer and alex
kurtzman critics say anchored by the
incomparable patrick sewer picard
departs from standard starfleet protocol
with a slower serialized story but like
all great star trek it tackles timely
themes with grace and makes for an
exciting push further into the final
frontier
[Music]
[Music]
picard
you're alive
this fills me with joy heads up
so are you here to help with the cleanup
or you just make messes
i don't believe it
for a few minutes i felt
connected to everything i saw everything
i saw serena and the transwarp conduit i
saw the snakehead chasing it so you
opened another conduit and came after us
you needed our help
thank you
you're welcome
poor hugh
it must have taken appalling brutality
to turn such a gentle soul to violence
what are they doing i'm using a battery
pack to try and get the food replicators
back online
are the systems operational
what do you need
long-range scanners it can be
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time i'm your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you